What I like particularly with "Dinner in the Sky" is that it's a very creative concept.
Creative about the table in itself,...
...the food you give to all your 22 guests and also about what you are doing on the table.
Because you can do a meeting,...
...you can do all sorts of things connected with gastronomy...
...or not connected with gastronomy.
Then, the location is very important.
Here, Dolce La Hulpe welcomes us in a really outstanding location.
But we can also have other locations connected to national marvels...
...like the Grand Canyon, for instance, like the Niagara Falls.
People talking to us, they want to have it in Masai Mara,...
...to have "Dinner in the Sky" at Festival de Cannes.
We are very mobile so we can go everywhere and in every location...
...without spoiling anything.
The last thing where we can be creative is what we are doing today,...
...is to have a sudden crane...
...and to organize an original entertainment for our guests.
Today, we have a piano here and a violin.
So we can entertain them with music.
But we can also be more practical with,...
...for instance, a presentation in the sky.
It's just a table, it's a table in the sky.
So it's not a question of function.
It's connected with a child's dream,...
...with what you had in mind when you were children.
With "Dinner in the Sky," it works great. Really, I say that the sky's the limit!